لا مفاجات كبرى
في التنفيذ
باندفاعها يمينا تثبت هذه الحكومه الاقصى
في قلب المواجهه تدليس باحاته من قبل زعيم
الصهيونيه الدينيه
الذي اقتحامها وهو وزير هذه المره نبه
قاده معارضه الاسرائيليه الى خطوره تبعاته
اما الاداره العربيه والدوليه لفعله وزير
الامن القومي في حكومه نتنياهو الجديده
فما ذلك تتلاحق
في الجانب الفلسطيني تبرز مطالبه رئيس
المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس اسماعيل هنيه
في مذكره بعثها لقاده المنطقه بموقف واضح
وحاسم تجاه جهود الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الراميه الى شطب حقوق الشعب الفلسطيني
والسيطره على ارضه وتهويد مقدساته الاضرار
بالوضع القائم فيما يتعلق بالاماكن
المقدسه في القدس هو ما تعارضه بشده الامم
المتحده والولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي وهنا ترفض المانيا
احاديه الجانب تعرض الوضع التاريخيه
الراهنه في الحرم القدسي للخطر
الحكومه الالمانيه ترفض الخطوات الاحاديه
الجانب التي تعرض الوضع التاريخي الراهنه
في الحرم القدسي للخطر وقد اوضحنا مرارا
وتكرارا ان زياره هي استفزاز لذلك نرفض
بوضوح هذا النهج ونتوقع ان تلتزم الحكومه
اسرائيليه جديده بمواصله الممارسات الجيده
حول الاماكن المقدسه في القدس ووقف المزيد
من الاستفزازات المتعمده والسماح لجميع
المؤمنين والمهتمين بالوصول الى هذه
المنطقه وفي نفس الوقت ضمان تنفيذ
احتفالات المسلمين والصلاه في المسجد
الاقصى وحوله بطريقه كريمه لا يجد بن جرير
من يدافع عن خطوته المجمع على طابعها
الاستفزازي لكن هل ستنعكس موجه الاستنكار
الدولي موقفا حازما في المنابر الدوليه
تدفع نحو ذلك مشاعل دبلوماسيه فلسطين
وعربيه ودوليه لعقد جلسه لمجلس الامن
ستناقش الجلسه كما يفترض التطورات في
القدس على خلفيه اقتحام وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي للمسجد الاقصى وربما تنضم الى
قضيه بحسب مسؤول الفلسطيني اعتداءات
مستوطنين يهود على مقابر مسيحيين في القدس
لن تدخر تل ابيبوس عن لابطال هذا المسعى
يكشفوا موقعه ولا الاخباريه الاسرائيلي
صحيح حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو لاحباط صدور
اي قرار او بيان باسم اعضاء المجلس
ويوضح الموقع ان هذه المساعي تضمنتها
برقيه سريه لوزاره الخارجيه الاسرائيليه
ارسلت الى حوالي 15 سفاره وممثليه
اسرائيليه حول العالم
تخشى الحكومه الجديده في اسرائيل فيما يرى
متابعون من صدور ما يرددوا بالسياساتها في
الاقصى بعد اقل من اسبوع على تشكيلها ليس
فقط لان ذلك سيشكل انتصارا دبلوماسيا
وسياسيا للفلسطينيين وانما ايضا لانه قد
يعرض حكومه نتنياهو الدينيه المتطرفه
لمزيد من الضغوط في الداخل والخارج